I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。
Hello. Hi there. Every time I hear our little opening intro, and I hear a creed playing, it makes me happy. Me too. So just starting with that. It's a nice way to start a moment, a day? A podcast for sure. For sure.
你好。嗨。每次听到我们的开场白，听到克里德演奏的音乐，我都觉得很开心。我也是。从这一点开始就好。这是一个开启某个时刻或一天的不错方式？当然是播客。当然。
Our podcast for sure. Well, yes, that for sure. You wanna hear what we're talking about today? Oh, I do. I hope it's not a surprise to you. I hope not. For sure. Our podcast, for sure. Well, yes, that, for sure. You want to hear what we're talking about today? Oh, I do. I hope it's not a surprise to you. I hope not.
我们的播客当然。好吧，是的，那是肯定的。你想听听我们今天在聊什么吗？哦，我想。我希望这对你来说不是个惊喜。希望不是。当然。我们的播客，当然。好吧，是的，那是肯定的。你想听听我们今天在聊什么吗？哦，我想。我希望这对你来说不是个惊喜。希望不是。
It is The Whale. It is season nine, episode seven, written by Kerry Kemper and directed by Rodman Flender. Do you remember Rodman? I do. He was so fun. So fun. And I remember being like, Rodman, come back.
就是《白鲸记》。这是第九季第七集，由凯瑞·肯珀编剧，罗德曼·弗兰德导演。你还记得罗德曼吗？我记得。他太有趣了。太有趣了。我记得当时我说，罗德曼，回来吧。
I know. He's directed a ton of television and he has a very famous nephew, Timothy Chalamet. Can you believe it? Yeah. We didn't realize that back then. No. But Timothy Chalamet wasn't Timothy Chalamet back then. I know.
我知道。他导演了大量的电视节目，他有一个非常著名的侄女婿，蒂莫西·柴勒梅德。你敢相信吗？是的。我们当时并没有意识到这一点。没有。但那时候的蒂莫西·柴勒梅德还不是现在的蒂莫西·柴勒梅德。我知道。
Rodman, we would be asking for all the deets on your nephew. Yeah. What a talent. Like the annoying ants. We would. We would be like, what project is he in now? Yes, I, I, I, I notice he changed his hair and I like it. I think it frames his face nicely. Well, I love his fashion on the red carpet.
罗德曼，我们肯定会打听你侄女婿的所有八卦。是的。真是个天才。就像烦人的蚂蚁一样。我们会这样的。我们会问，他现在在拍什么项目？是的，我，我，我，我注意到他换了发型，我很喜欢。我觉得这很好地衬托了他的脸型。嗯，我很喜欢他在红毯上的时尚风格。
Yes, he takes chances. He takes risks. And he sticks with it. We love him, Rodman. We love him. Rodman's listening to this right now and he's like, thank God. Oh my gosh.
是的，他勇于尝试。他敢于冒险。并且一直坚持下去。我们爱你，罗德曼。我们爱你。罗德曼现在正在听这个，他会想，谢天谢地。哦，天哪。
All right, here is your summary. Dwight is tasked with securing a new client, so the ladies in the office attempt to teach him how to sell to women. Yeah. Because this new client is a woman. That's all we know about her at first. Yeah. A woman.
好了，这是剧情摘要。德怀特的工作是争取一个新客户，所以办公室里的女士们试图教他如何向女性推销。是的。因为这个新客户是个女性。一开始我们对她一无所知。是的。一个女性。
Oscar is going to help Angela investigate her hunch that the senator might be having an affair. And finally, Jim's telecommuting is not quite working out. No. He's trying to take a phone call. This reminds me of trying to have a private conversation when you have a house full of kids. You like duck into nooks and crannies, but everyone still finds you. Yeah. Yeah. We got a lot of mail about that particular storyline. I can't wait for us to discuss.
奥斯卡将协助安吉拉调查她的直觉，即参议员可能在搞婚外情。最后，吉姆的远程办公进展不太顺利。没有。他正试图接听一个电话。这让我想起当你家里塞满孩子时，试图进行一次私人对话的情景。你就像鸭子一样钻进各种犄角旮旯，但每个人还是能找到你。是的。是的。我们收到了很多关于这条特定故事线的邮件。我等不及我们来讨论了。
Ooh, good. All right, fast fact number one, this episode was written by Carrie Kemper, who is the sister of Ellie Kemper. And Carrie also plays Jan's assistant Molly. I thought she did so great as Molly. So good. I want to know more about Molly.
哦，太好了。好的，趣味事实一，这一集是由凯瑞·肯珀编剧的，她是艾莉·肯珀的姐姐。凯瑞还饰演了简的助手莫莉。我觉得她把莫莉演得太棒了。太棒了。我想了解更多关于莫莉的信息。
Well I reached out to Carrie to ask her some questions about this episode and I just love her. I mean, I love these Kempergals. I know, they're such good gals. Carrie told me that the original pitch for this episode was very different from the final script. It was originally called Land Jan. They knew that they were going to have Jan come back
我联系了凯瑞，向她询问了一些关于这一集的问题，我太喜欢她了。我是说，我喜欢这些肯珀家族的女孩。我知道，她们真是好女孩。凯瑞告诉我，这一集的最初构思和最终剧本有很大不同。它最初叫做《拿下简》。他们知道他们会让简回归，
and that she was going to be someone we were pitching to. And in the original pitch, Pam comes into work at the beginning of the day and she is so bummed because she ran into Jan at the grocery store and promised to go to lunch with her. But then Pam realizes that if she makes Dwight go with her that Jan will probably end the lunch that if she makes Dwight go with her, that Jan will probably end the lunch early because Jan hates Dwight. So Dwight and Pam go to lunch with Jan, and
而且她会成为我们要推销的对象。在最初的构思中，潘在一天开始时来上班，她非常沮丧，因为她在杂货店遇到了简，并答应和她去吃午饭。但随后潘意识到，如果她让德怀特跟她一起去，简可能会提前结束午饭，如果她让德怀特跟她一起去，简可能会提前结束午饭，因为简讨厌德怀特。所以德怀特和潘和简一起吃午饭，
while they're there, they realize that she wants to give them her business. Okay. And they start competing for who can sell Jan more paper, and it becomes very clear that Dwight is horrible at selling to women. Okay. So, Kerry said that Greg read the pitch and he zeroed in on one detail, which was that Dwight is terrible at selling to women. And Greg said, that's your story.
当他们在那里时，他们意识到她想把生意交给我们。好吧。他们开始争夺谁能向简推销更多的纸张，这变得非常明显，德怀特向女性推销简直糟透了。好吧。所以，凯瑞说格雷格读了这个构思，他把注意力集中在一个细节上，那就是德怀特向女性推销太糟糕了。格雷格说，这就是你的故事。
That's what it should be. And also, Jan should be a surprise. It should be a reveal. I 100% agree. This is the genius of Greg, right? I know that he could look at that pitch and then find the two things that were gonna make it zing.
这才是它该有的样子。而且，简应该是一个惊喜。这应该是一个揭秘。我百分之百赞同。这就是格雷格的天才之处，对吧？我知道他能看到那个构思，然后找到能让它大放异彩的两个细节。
Yes, so they changed the title to The Whale, and here we are. Carrie also said that the Oscar Angela Senator storyline was an absolute dream. She said the minute the writers pitched that and decided that that was going to be the storyline for this season, the whole story just kind of wrote itself. I have been so excited to get to these episodes because of my whole entire time on the office.
是的，所以他们把剧集标题改成了《白鲸记》，然后我们就来到了这里。凯瑞还说，奥斯卡、安吉拉和参议员的故事线简直是个美梦。她说编剧们一提出这个构思，并决定这将是这一季的故事线时，整个故事就像是自己写出来了。我一直非常兴奋能看到这些集数，因为我在《办公室》的整个时间里，
I know I had amazing scenes with Rain and we got to play out the Dwight and Angela romance, but these scenes with Oscar are some of my absolute favorites. And you know, you guys remember Oscar and I met doing sketch comedy, like, you know, my gosh, 20 years ago. And to be able to do these scenes with him was just pure joy. We were giddy. It was so fun. Carrie said that the two of you together is absolute magic. And she said that she felt like this particular beat of the story of you guys
我知道我和雷恩有精彩的对手戏，我们演绎了德怀特和安吉拉的浪漫史，但这些和奥斯卡的对手戏是我绝对最喜欢的。你知道，大家还记得我和奥斯卡是20年前做素描喜剧时认识的，天哪。能和他在这些场景中合作简直是纯粹的快乐。我们当时欣喜若狂。太有趣了。凯瑞说你们两个在一起简直是魔术。她说她觉得故事中你们俩观看这堂瑜伽课的特定情节，
watching this yoga class. She said she felt like she won the lottery because this was her particular favorite beat of the storyline and she got it. Thanks, Carrie. I know. Well, you know, I also asked Carrie how she got her job on the office because we got a lot of mail. People were curious if Ellie had anything to do with it. And Carrie said that Ellie kind of did, that Ellie had been on the show for about a year and she was sitting with Claire Scanlon one day and Claire told her that Greg and Paul were setting some meetings
就像中了大奖一样，因为这是她整条故事线中最喜欢的特定情节，而且她得到了它。谢谢你，凯瑞。我知道。嗯，你知道的，我还问过凯瑞她是如何得到《办公室》的工作的，因为我们收到了很多邮件。人们很好奇艾莉是否在其中起了什么作用。凯瑞说艾莉确实有点关系，艾莉已经在剧组呆了一年左右，有一天她和克莱尔·斯坎伦坐在一起，克莱尔告诉她格雷格和保罗正在为第七季寻找新的潜在女性编剧安排会议，
for new potential female writers for season seven. And Ellie said, my sister is a TV writer. But the thing was, was that Carrie was an aspiring TV writer. She'd never actually had a job writing for television. She had been the editor of her College Humor Magazine, but she was at the very beginning of her career. But she had three spec scripts.
艾莉说，我姐姐是个电视编剧。但问题是，凯瑞当时只是一个立志成为电视编剧的人。她从来没有真正做过电视编剧的工作。她曾担任过她大学幽默杂志的主编，但她正处于职业生涯的初期。不过她有三个剧本样品。
Do people know what spec scripts are? I think we've shared about it. They're like a script that you write as a sample of your work, of what you can do. Yeah, so you'll pick a show that's already on television and then you'll write an episode of it. So she had written spec scripts of the Sarah Silverman program. She did one for 30 Rock and she did one for Modern Family.
人们知道什么是剧本样品吗？我想我们分享过。它们就像你写的一个剧本，作为你作品的样品，展示你能做什么。是的，所以你会选择一个已经在电视上播出的节目，然后写一集。所以她写过《萨拉·西尔弗曼节目》的剧本样品。她为《我本千金》写过一个，为《摩登家庭》写过一个。
And so Claire agreed to pass on her Modern Family spec script to Paul. And Paul read it and he called her in. He loved it. He called her in for a meeting and Carrie was like, oh, he's just being nice because my sister's on the show. And listen to what her mom said. I love their mom.
所以克莱尔同意把她的《摩登家庭》剧本样品转交给保罗。保罗读了之后打电话给她。他很喜欢。他叫她去开会，凯瑞当时想，哦，他只是在客套，因为我姐姐在这个节目里。听听她妈妈是怎么说的。我太喜欢他们的妈妈了。
Her mom said, do you think he has time to be nice? Oh, yeah. This is a real meeting. You own it. You got yourself in the door with this good script. Good moming. I like that. So Carrie went to the meeting and she said after the meeting, he asked for
她妈妈说，你觉得他有时间客套吗？哦，是的。这是一次真正的会议。你得把握住。你凭着这个好剧本打开了局面。好妈妈发言。我喜欢这个。所以凯瑞去开会了，她说会后，他要求
another writing sample. So she sent him a one act play that she written, and she got hired a week later. That's such a great story. Mm-hmm. She said the office was her favorite TV show. It was her first job writing on television. But, you know, she has gone on to write on some of seriously the best stuff on TV. Silicon Valley.
另一个写作样品。于是她发给他一个她写过的独幕剧，一周后她就被雇用了。这真是一个伟大的故事。嗯哼。她说《办公室》是她最喜欢的电视节目。这是她从事电视写作的第一份工作。但是，你知道，她后来为电视上一些最棒的作品写过剧本。《硅谷》。
Oh, man. Beef. Oh. The rehearsal. And she's currently co-executive producer of The Curse, which is now streaming on Paramount Plus. There you go. I love that story.
哦，天哪。《怒呛人生》。哦。《排练》。她目前是《诅咒》的联合执行制片人，该剧目前正在派拉蒙+上播放。你看。我喜欢这个故事。
I also just love the bond of sisterhood. That Ellie, without any hesitation, was like, my sister's a writer. Yeah. So great. I know. All the women in that family helped carry, right? Yes.
我也很喜欢姐妹情谊。艾莉毫不犹豫地说，我姐姐是个作家。是的。太棒了。我知道。那个家庭里的所有女性都帮助了凯瑞，对吧？是的。
Like have the courage, the confidence, and the opportunity. I love it. All right. Fast fact number two, another big storyline in this episode, which I failed to mention in my summary, is that all the men in the office are growing mustaches. Yes, they are. Do you say mustache or moustache? Who says moustache?
比如拥有勇气、自信和机遇。我喜欢这个。好的。趣味事实二，这一集中的另一个大故事线，我在摘要中漏掉了，那就是办公室里所有的男士都在留胡子。是的，他们都在留。你们说“mustache”还是“moustache”？谁会说“moustache”？
I realize. That's like a Muppet. A Muppet says moustache. Is that from Sesameache? I realize... That's like a Muppet. A Muppet says moustache. You know what I realize? Is that from Sesame Street? No, that's how I... Is that how you say moustache as one of your animals?
我意识到。那听起来像个布偶。布偶才会说“moustache”。那是来自《芝麻街》吗？我意识到……那听起来像个布偶。布偶才会说“moustache”。你知道我意识到什么吗？那是来自《芝麻街》吗？不，这就是我……那是你用来模仿某种动物的发音吗？
Yes, that's how Sunny says moustache. Okay, you guys know... Because he has a little white moustache. I know. Jenna does the voices of her pets. We all do. That's why I was like, I almost said moustache. And then as I said it out loud, I realized no one says that, just Sunny.
是的，桑尼就是这样说“moustache”的。好吧，你们知道……因为他有一小撮白胡子。我知道。珍娜会模仿她宠物发出的声音。我们都会。这就是为什么我当时想，我差点说成“moustache”。然后当我大声说出来时，我意识到没有人那样说，只有桑尼。
Just Sunny. Sunny would say, oh my God, you have a really nice moustache. And you're made up voice for him. Yeah. Anyway, all right. So all the men in the office are growing mustaches for Movember. Movember is an annual event every November. Men grow a mustache to help raise awareness for men's health issues like prostate cancer.
只有桑尼。桑尼会说，哦天哪，你留了一撮真棒的胡子。然后你用捏造的声音为他配音。是的。不管怎样，好吧。所以办公室里所有的男士都在为“胡子月”留胡子。“胡子月”是每年11月份的一个活动。男士们留胡子是为了提高人们对前列腺癌等男性健康问题的意识。
A lot of people do fundraisers in conjunction with growing their mustache. We got a fan letter from Keith S. in Los Angeles who said, I work for Movember and I worked there in 2012 when this episode was written. And I would love to answer any questions anyone may have about Movember or how we worked with the writers to make sure there was an accurate representation of our organization.
很多人在留胡子的同时还会举办筹款活动。我们收到了来自洛杉矶的基思·S的粉丝信，他说，我为“胡子月”工作，2012年这一集拍摄时我就在那里工作。我很乐意回答任何人关于“胡子月”或者我们如何与编剧合作以确保准确代表我们组织的任何问题。
Way to go, Keith. I love that you wrote in. He said he loves the podcast and he's been waiting for this episode. So we did reach out to Keith. And here's what he said. He said the writing staff reached out and let them know that they were going to use Movember in a storyline, but they didn't share the script. But they checked to make sure that they were allowed to use it in the way they were using it
干得好，基思。我很高兴你写信来。他说他很喜欢这个播客，一直在等待这一集。所以我们确实联系了基思。以下是他说的话。他说编剧团队联系过他们，让他们知道他们将在故事线中使用“胡子月”，但他们没有分享剧本。不过他们核实了他们是否被允许以这种方式使用它，
and wanted to make sure that they got it accurate. Mm-hmm. He also heard that some of the writers had participated in Movember. And I remember that, Ian. I do, too. So, he said they were just thrilled that the office talked about Movember correctly, and it was such a great public platform.
并希望确保他们做到准确无误。嗯哼。他还听说一些编剧也参与了“胡子月”。我记得那个，伊恩。我也记得。所以，他说他们非常高兴《办公室》能正确地谈论“胡子月”，这是一个如此棒的公共平台。
He said the whole team had a watch party to watch the episode, and he said they still share a gif of Toby saying, smile if you love men's prostates on Slack. Keith said the writers also sent over a cookie bouquet of mustache and office themed cookies when the episode aired. I love that. Isn't that so sweet? Keith did want to say that Movember has come a long way since the whale. He said they always focused on prostate and testicular cancer,
他说整个团队办了一个观影派对来观看这一集，他说他们现在仍然在Slack上分享托比说“如果你喜欢男人的前列腺就笑一笑”的动图。基思说，当这一集播出时，编剧们还送来了一束胡子和办公室主题的饼干花束。我喜欢这个。是不是太贴心了？基思确实想说，“胡子月”自《白鲸记》以来已经取得了长足的进步。他说他们过去总是关注前列腺癌和睾丸癌，
but they now also raise awareness and funds for men's mental health and suicide prevention. He said that since 2003, they have built a global men's health movement funding more than 1,300 projects. And he said, our listeners can learn more or donate at movember.com. Keith, I will put that in our stories with a swipe up.
但现在他们也为男人的心理健康和预防自杀提高意识并筹集资金。他说自2003年以来，他们已经建立了全球男性健康运动，资助了1300多个项目。他说，我们的听众可以在movember.com了解更多信息或进行捐赠。基思，我会把这个放在我们的故事里，带向上滑动功能。
And thanks so much for writing in. Yeah, thank you, Keith. Oh, one more thing. He did want to give a shout out to Lisa, Abby, and Caitlin for helping him with all these details. Awesome. All right. Fast fact number three.
非常感谢你写信来。是的，谢谢你，基思。哦，还有一件事。他确实想向丽莎、艾比和凯特琳表示感谢，感谢她们在所有这些细节上给予他的帮助。太棒了。好的。趣味事实三。
I'm very excited, everyone, because Angela has asked for fast fact number three. And we are now going to have a mailbag moment with Angela Kinsey. A mailbag moment. By the way, Cody, who works on Office Ladies, told us there's even more mail that we need to go through. There's been even more. A new pile. A new stack of mail. Or as Sunny would say, a pall. A polymol. Well, this letter is from Jacqueline, and Jacqueline, the envelope was a little bent
大家我很兴奋，因为安吉拉要求了趣味事实三。我们现在要和安吉拉·金西有一个收件箱时刻。一个收件箱时刻。顺便说一句，在《办公室女郎》工作的科迪告诉我们，还有更多邮件需要我们处理。还有更多。新的一堆。新的一堆邮件。或者正如桑尼所说，一堆“pall”。一个“polymol”。好吧，这封信来自杰奎琳，杰奎琳，信封角有点折了，但我认为你来自加拿大，来自加拿大的杰奎琳·S。我当时想看看邮票，我太喜欢这封信了，珍娜，我想分享一下。杰奎琳写信说，亲爱的珍娜和安吉拉，我的丈夫在大流行期间把我引入了《办公室》，
in the corner, but I think you're from Canada, Jacqueline S. from Canada. I was trying to see the postage stamp, and I just loved this letter, Jenna, and I wanted to share it. Jacqueline wrote in and said, Dear Jenna and Angela, my husband introduced me to the office during the pandemic,
只用了大约五分钟我就迷上了。当新冠肺炎肆虐，一切似乎都处于不断变化和未知状态时，《办公室》成了我的安全港湾，我很快就刷完了整个系列，然后回去一遍又一遍地观看最喜欢的剧集。就在我以为自己不可能再爱上任何东西时，我发现了《办公室女郎》播客。虽然在我们从未正式见面的时候感谢你感觉有点奇怪，但在听完整整两遍播客之后，
and it took about five minutes before I was hooked. While COVID was raging on and everything seemed to be in a constant state of flux and the unknown, the office became my safe place and I quickly benched the entire series before going back and watching favorite episodes again and again. Just when I thought I couldn't love anything more, I found the Office Ladies podcast. While it feels odd to thank you when we have never properly met, having listened to the entire podcast twice already,
我知道，我觉得我们是朋友。我花了无数的时间听你们俩来回打趣，因为你们每周都分享那么多关于自己的事，很容易让人忘记你们不是我现实生活中的朋友。就像闺蜜聊天，分享你们一周的最新动态。我想分享你们的播客对我有多重要。你们让我笑，让我哭，让我思考，还引发了许多深入的探讨。好的。不，我喜欢这个。
I know, I feel like we are friends. I have spent countless hours listening to the two of you banter back and forth, and because you share so much of yourselves each week, it's easy to forget you are not my real life friends. Just having a girl chat, sharing updates about your week. I wanted to share how much your podcast means to me. You've made me laugh, cry, think, and have spurred many a deep dive. All right. No, I love that.
接着她说她经历了几年的重大生活转变。她有了第一个宝宝。她去休产假，重返工作岗位，他们装修了房子，她的父亲被诊断出患有癌症，然后她又怀上了第二个宝宝。她写道，虽然大多数时候生活可能会让人觉得有点疯狂，但你们的播客是一个不变的陪伴，我喂母乳时听，
She goes on to say that she had a few years of real big life transitions. She had her first baby. She went on maternity leave, went back to work, they renovated their house, her father was diagnosed with cancer, and then she became pregnant with their second baby. And she writes this, while most of the time life can feel a little crazy, your podcast is a constant, I listened to it while I breastfed,
失眠时听，做饭和打扫卫生时听，在车里听，当我哭泣需要转移注意力时听，以及当我想笑时听。我的女性友谊对我很重要。虽然我真的很喜欢《办公室》，但现在是你们的播客让我不断回听。对我来说，它是对女性友谊和关系的庆祝，这是世界所需要的更多东西。谢谢你们每周倾注的爱、精力和关怀。杰奎琳，你的信，非常感谢你花时间写这封信。这对我非常触动，哇，你在过去几年里经历了太多，我们很高兴能陪伴你度过这一切，在你的耳边，陪伴你，转移你的注意力，无论我们能做些什么。引发深入探讨。
when I couldn't sleep, while I cooked and cleaned, when I was in the car, when I was crying and needed a distraction and when I wanted to laugh. My female friendships are so important to me. And while I really do love the office, it is now your podcasts that I keep coming back to. To me, it is a celebration of female friendships
是的，你知道，制作播客对我来说也是同样的基石。每周来到这里制作这个播客，无论我的生活还在发生什么，所有的事，因为我们总是有所有的事，因为我们总是有所有的事，你知道吗？是的，每个人都承受着很多。
and relationships, something that the world needs more of. Thank you for the love and energy and care you put into it each and every week. Jacqueline, your letter, thank you so much for taking the time to write that letter. That it was very touching to me and wow, you have been through a lot in the last couple of years and we're happy to be there with you through all of it, in your ear, keeping you company, keeping you distracted, whatever we can do. Spurring on a deep dive.
是的，我们不知道每个人都在承受什么，但每个人都有点事情，对吧？是的。对我来说，制作它也是同样的逃避、释放、欢笑和乐趣，听起来当杰奎琳收听时它也是这样，这让我感到非常高兴。我也是，读到那封信我太高兴了。杰奎琳，谢谢你花时间写信给我们。就像珍娜说的，我们一直在为你支持。好吧，我想现在是休息一下的好时机。
Yes, and you know, the thing is, is that making the podcast is that same touchstone for me. Coming in here each week and making this podcast, whatever else is going on in my life, all of the things, cause we all always have all of the things, because we all always have all of the things, you know? Yes, everybody is caring so much.
是的，因为当我们回来时，我们要去赶上安迪。他在他的船上，情况不太好。不，情况确实不好。我们回到了安迪的船上，他大概在用某种形式的FaceTime和——我想他在用Skype？Skype！是的，Skype。他们说Skype？我当然会弄错。
Yeah, and we don't know what everybody is carrying, but everyone's got something, right? Yep. And this is that same escape and release and laughter and fun for me, making it that it sounds like it is for Jacqueline when she listens and it makes me so happy. Me too, it made me so happy to read that letter. Jacqueline, thank you for taking the time to write us. And like Jenna said, we're here for you. Well, I think that is a nice time to take a break.
我会把所有这些都弄错。人们现在还用Skype吗？我不知道。你在用Skype，我们现在用Zoom，对吧？现在我们用Zoom。我们用过Skype，然后用FaceTime，现在用Zoom。我仍然和我妈妈用FaceTime，但她把它叫做Facebook。所以她会说，你想Facebook一下吗？
Yes, because when we come back, we're gonna catch up with Andy. He's on his boat, it's not going well. No, it is not. We are back on Andy's boat and he's, I guess, doing some form of FaceTime with- I think he's Skyping? Skype! Yes, Skype. They said Skype? Of course I would get that wrong.
我说，是FaceTime。是的。但我正在变成我妈妈。你确实在慢慢变成。慢慢地。他跟每个人分享他一直在单曲循环看《辣身舞》，而且他晒得很严重，因为小沃尔特把防晒霜都囤积起来了。
I'm gonna get all of that wrong. Do people still Skype? I don't know. You're Skyping, now we Zoom, right? Now we Zoom. We Skyped, then we FaceTimed, now we Zoom. I still FaceTime with my mom, but she calls it Facebook. So she'll say, do you want a Facebook?
是的，当他跟每个人说话时，他设法把他的饮用水掉进了海里。然后他把脱盐器也掉进了海里，你知道吗？他看起来糟透了。他看起来像疯了。我知道。他确实是。达瑞尔说，你知道吗？他才航海两天。是的。我的意思是，他看起来像在海上呆了好几个月。这个场景里有一些备选台词。你知道当安吉拉说，多担心我的眼睛，因为它们在我的眼窝里变成了燃烧的肉丸时？是的，是的。
I'm like, FaceTime. Yeah. But I am becoming my mom. You are, slowly. Slowly. He shares with everyone that he's been watching dirty dancing on repeat, and he's super sunburned because Walter Jr. has been hoarding all the sunscreen.
这是他的备选台词。如果你想担心我身体的某个部位，就担心我的眼睛吧。今天早上用海胆刷了牙。天哪。我知道。我觉得编剧们在构思这些安迪的船上的情节时玩得很开心。其中另一句台词是他说的，
Yeah, while he's talking with everyone, he manages to drop his drinking water overboard. Then he drops his desalinator overboard, and you know what? He looks awful. He looks like he's going crazy. I know. He does. Darrell says, you know what? He's only been sailing for two days. Yeah. I mean, he looks like he's been out to sea for months. There were some alts within this scene. You know when Andy says, be more worried about my eyes because they've become flaming meatballs in my skull? Yes, yes.
我的皮肤现在太敏感了。我人生中穿衬衫的部分已经结束了，伙计们。他再也不穿衬衫了。不，就是这样。他不穿衬衫了。他没有防晒霜，但他要脱掉衬衫。真是个好主意。是的，我知道。我们在拉斯维加斯的奥利维亚B有一个粉丝问题，她非常喜欢这句台词“让我的头发远离我的凝视。还能帮我对抗耀眼的熊”。我也很喜欢这句台词，奥利维亚。奥利维亚想知道是谁写的这句台词。哦，我来猜一下。
Here was his alt. If you wanna worry about some part of my body, worry about my eyes. Brushed my teeth with a sea urch in this AM. Boy. I know. I think the writers had a lot of fun pitching this Andy boat stuff. One of the other lines was he said,
你找到了吗？我找到了。凯瑞告诉我。是布伦特吗？不是，但这真是一个很好的猜测，因为他喜欢双关语。我知道。那是谁写的？
my skin's too sensitive now. The shirt part of my life is over, dudes. He's not going to wear shirts anymore. No, that's it. He's done with shirts. He has no sunscreen, but he's going to take off his shirt. That's a great idea. Yeah, I know. We had a fan question from Olivia B in Las Vegas who really loved the line keeps my hair out of my stare. Also helps me combat the glare bear. I love that line too, Olivia. Olivia wanted to know who wrote that line. Oh, I have a guess.
虽然那不是双关语，更像是一个押韵，对吧？我知道，但还是很像布伦特。非常像布伦特。好吧，凯瑞说，奥利维亚，我很高兴你问这个问题。这是我们的编剧格雷厄姆·瓦格纳写的。她说，格雷厄姆是个好朋友。他们后来一起为《硅谷》写剧本。她说她完全记得当格雷厄姆提出这句台词时，他们在保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室里笑得前俯后仰。
Did you find out? I did. Carrie told me. Was it Brent? It was not, but that is such a good guess because he loves the puns. I know. Who was it?
哦，真喜欢那个。她很高兴你能欣赏它。好吧，格雷厄姆，干得好。当安吉拉把船舷外所有重要的东西都扔掉，包括他的笔记本电脑时，我写了两个词。什么？笨手笨脚。哦，因为他真的是个笨手笨脚的人。
Although that's not a pun, it's more of a rhyme, right? I know, but still, very Brent. Very Brent. Okay, Carrie said, Olivia, I am so happy you asked this question. It was written by our writer, Graham Wagner. She said, Graham is a good friend. They went on to write on Silicon Valley together. And she said she completely remembers cracking up in Paul Lieberstein's office when Graham pitched that line.
这是我爸爸以前常说的话，当我们像青少年一样在屋里跺着脚走路然后掉东西时，我爸爸就会说，有人得了笨手笨脚症。好吧，我得告诉你，我们真的是在船上拍的。我们在拍船的那周前一周拍摄了安吉拉这一边的对话。拍摄笔记本电脑掉进水里的那一镜头是一个非常耗时的镜头。我敢打赌。
Oh, love that. She's so glad you appreciated it. Well, Graham, way to go. As Andy's dropping everything that's important over the side of the boat, including his laptop, I wrote two words. What? Fumble fingers. Oh, because he has a real fumble fingers.
所以他们做的是，我们的摄影指导用了一个防水的GoPro相机，并把它绑在一根棍子上，因为他们必须确保相机不会真的沉下去，对吧？但他们也必须确保它看起来逼真。所以就像有人多次像这样用棍子拿着GoPro看起来像掉落，然后上下晃动诸如此类的事情。同样在那个场景中，我们有一个真正的船长。他的名字叫克里斯·罗伯逊，他躺在驾驶舱底部开着船。
This is the thing my dad used to say when we were like teenagers clomping through the house and we would drop things, my dad would be like, someone's got a case of the fumble fingers. Well, I'll have you know, we really shot that on a boat. We shot Andy's side of the conversation the week prior when we were shooting the boat. Getting that shot of the laptop going into the water was a really time-consuming shot. I bet.
哦，天哪。我们拍这个镜头时全程都在。他就像被藏起来了，但是是的。你知道最后那个时刻，安吉拉说，他摆出一个姿势，就像是，让这成为一个在船上的男人的持久记忆？是的。我在一分二十七秒有一个背景抓拍。那是什么？潘、达瑞尔、安吉拉、菲利斯、奥斯卡和艾伦都在看着安吉拉
So what they did was our cinematographer put a waterproof GoPro camera and he attached it to a stick because they had to make sure that the camera didn't really sink, right? But they also had to make sure it looked realistic. So it was like many times of someone like using this GoPro on a stick to look like fall and then bobbing and all that sort of stuff. Also during the scene, we had a real boat captain. His name was Chris Robertson and he was laying on the bottom of the cockpit driving the boat.
当他把电脑扔进水里时。你甚至听到我们做出反应，哦，然后在在一分三十六秒，我们都不见了。只剩下艾伦和达瑞尔。我们立刻离开了。立刻。大家都溜了。我记得那天早上拍那个，安吉拉。你知道，我们并没有真的和他现场连线。没有。
Oh my gosh. The whole time we did this shot. He was like hidden, but yeah. You know the very last moment where Andy says, he strikes a pose and is like, let this be the lasting memory of a man on a boat? Yes. I have a background catch at one minute, 27 seconds. What's that? Pam, Darryl, Angela, Phyllis, Oscar, and Aaron are all watching Andy
但他们确实在电脑上把它调出来了。我记得当我看到他的妆容时，我是真的震惊了，他的脸，他的嘴唇。他的嘴唇太让人不安了。我觉得他们用了我们真实的反应。因为我记得。我记得完全吓坏了。我说，哦，天哪。哦，天哪，埃德，你怎么了？
as he drops his computer into the water. You even hear us react like, oh, and then at one minute, 36 seconds, we're all gone. Only Aaron and Darryl remain. We left immediately. Immediately. Everyone bailed. I remember shooting that that morning, Angela. You know, we were not really live with him. No.
好吧，让我们进入这一集的正题。或者我应该说这一集的油腻部分？大卫·华尔士要打电话给德怀特并告诉他一些消息。是的。他非常兴奋，把他设为免提，只想把他取消免提，因为他不想让吉姆听到。好吧，我的意思是，吉姆把主电话的手柄部分扯掉了，现在他不得不开免提。
But they did bring it up on the computer. And I remember being like legitimately shocked when I saw the makeup job of his like, his face, his lips. His lips were so disturbing. I think they used our real reaction. Because I remember it. I remember being completely horrified. I was like, oh my gosh. Oh my God, Ed, what happened to you?
是的。我们得知的是，斯克兰顿白页公司已经换掉了合作10年的纸业供应商，他们现在成了香饽饽。他想让德怀特和吉姆去拿下这门生意。他说他想要顶尖的销售员，那就是德怀特。是的。德怀特欣喜若狂。他太兴奋了。
Well, let's get into the meat of this episode. Or should I say the blubber of this episode? David Wallace is going to call Dwight and tell him some news. Yeah. He's very excited, puts him on speakerphone only to want to take him off speakerphone because he doesn't want Jim to hear. Well, I mean, Jim rips the handheld part off the main phone and now he's got to be on speaker.
兴奋极了。他有一个访谈镜头，他说，白页不是那种你想要或需要的东西，但它还是会出现在你的门廊上。这就是为什么它被称为白鲸。然后他翻阅所有的页面说，看看所有那些甜美的脂肪。需要很多纸才能做出白页。
Yes. And what we learn is that the Scranton white pages have dropped their paper supplier of 10 years and they are up for grabs. And he wants Dwight and Jim to go and get this business. He says he wants the top salesman, which is Dwight. Yeah. Dwight is over the moon. He's so excited.
这是一笔大买卖。我想可能是时候来个小小深入探讨了。关于白页？关于有史以来的第一本电话簿。哦，有史以来第一本。我太好奇了。我想，你知道的，我喜欢起源故事。所以这里有一些关于有史以来第一本电话簿的信息。
So excited. He has a talking head where he says, the white pages aren't something that you want or need, but it shows up on your doorstep anyway. And there's a reason why it's called the white whale. And then he flips through all the pages and he says, look at all that sweet blubber. Need a lot of paper to make the white pages.
这一切都发生在康涅狄格州。康涅狄格州。他会为此感到骄傲的。是的。这是育空图书馆网站分享的内容。乔治·科伊是康涅狄格州纽黑文市一个电报局的经理，他在1877年4月观看了发明家亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔对电话的演示。
This is a big score. I think it might be time for a little mini dive. On the white pages? On the first ever phone book. Oh, the first ever. I was so curious. I was like, you know, I love an origin story. So here's a little bit about the first phone book ever.
这促使科伊在1878年1月建立了世界上第一个公共电话交换所。女士们，上面说他用马车螺栓、茶壶盖和电线制作了一个八路线路的交换机。我的意思是，这感觉有点像《百战天龙》的动作。是的。
It all went down in Connecticut. Connecticut. And he would be so proud. Yeah. Here's what the Yukon Library website had to share. George Coy was the manager of a telegraph office in New Haven, Connecticut, and he attended a demonstration of the telephone
对吧？这感觉就像你孩子在科学课上做的事情。我知道，但它成功了，纽黑文地区电话公司成立了。这是世界上第一家公共电话公司。哇。该公司创造了另一个第一。它制作了有史以来第一本电话名录。名录上列出了50位客户，但没有电话号码。
by inventor Alexander Graham Bell in April 1877. This led to Koi establishing the world's first public telephone exchange in January of 1878. Lady, it says he used carriage bolts, teapot lids, and wire to make a switchboard of eight lines. I mean, this feels like a little MacGyver action. Yeah.
哦，是的。我怎么打电话给他们？好吧，对我们现在来说，这可能看起来很奇怪，但在当时……这有多少页？我的意思是只有三页。就像一个小册子。我见过它的照片。好吧，它是这样运作的，因为每个电话都是人工接听的，你知道的，你不用拨号，不，你是通过一个中央交换台接线员接听的，
Right? It feels like something your kid does in science class. I know, but it worked, and the New Haven District Telephone Company was established. And it was the first public telephone company in the world. Wow. The company established another first. It produced the first ever telephone directory. The directory listed 50 customers with no phone numbers.
而且订户名单太小了，不需要电话号码。当然，你只需呼叫那个人，呼叫交换台，然后你会说……帮我接通。给任何人。对。是的，安吉拉·金西。如果你在小册子里，我就会知道你有电话。没错。令人惊奇的是，这家公司不断发展并经历了许多不同的配置，但它一直为康涅狄格州提供独立的电信服务，直到1998年。哇。
Oh, yeah. How do I call them? Well, to us now, this might seem odd, but back then... How many pages was this? It was I mean just three pages. It's like a little pamphlet. I saw a picture of it. Okay Here's how it worked since every call was connected manually, you know, you didn't dial a number No, you were connected by a central switchboard operator and The subscriber list was so small, no numbers were necessary. Sure, you would just dial up the person, the switchboard, and you'd be like... Connect me to.
我知道。我喜欢阅读事物的起源，但这也让我想起了一个更简单的时间。当我搬到德克萨斯州阿彻城时，我会问别人的电话号码，他们只会给你四位数。因为前几位都一样吗？是的，而且小镇太小了。所以我从印度尼西亚搬来，你知道，然后我搬到了这个小镇，我以为每个人只有四个数字。
To whoever. Right. Yeah, Angela Kinsey. If you were in the pamphlet, I'd know you have a phone. That's right. What's amazing is this company grew and went through many different configurations, but it provided independent telecommunication service to the state of Connecticut until 1998. Wow.
太搞笑了。当我上大学时，我会问，你的四位数是什么？我知道，一想到这个就觉得疯狂。人们会说，安吉，难道你不需要全部的吗？我说，不，我只需要四个。他们会说，不。我需要后四位。不。
I know. I love reading about the origin of things, but also reminded me of a simpler time. And when I moved to Archer City, Texas, I would ask for people's phone numbers and they would just give you four digits. Because the first ones were all the same? Yes, and the town was so small. So I moved from Indonesia, you know, and then I moved to the small town and I thought everyone just had four numbers.
你还记得411吗？是的。那现在还存在吗？就像你过去常打411，说，我在找某个东西的电话号码，比如刘易斯轮胎。我不知道，我们应该打过去吗？当然，我的意思是，我很害怕。
That's so funny. And when I went to college, I would be like, what are your four numbers? I know, it's just crazy to think about. People were like, don't you need all of them, Ang? I'm like, no, I just need four. And they're like, nope. I need the last four. Nope.
你现在拨411会发生什么？我们不要害怕。好吧，我们现在拨411会怎么样？我们不要害怕。我们要问什么？问一家必胜客。好的。您呼叫的服务无法从此位置提供。哦。如果这是一场紧急情况。
Do you remember 411? Yes. Is that still a thing? Like you used to call up 411 and be like, I'm looking for the phone number of something like Lewis's tires. I don't know, should we call it? Sure, I mean, I'm scared.
哦。好吧，我们现在永远买不到必胜客了。不。我想我今天只能不吃披萨了。现在你让我对披萨感到饥饿了。抱歉。好吧，就是这样。一点第一本电话簿的起源。
What happens when you dial 411 now? Let's not be scared. Well, what are dial 411 now? Let's not be scared. What are we going to ask for? Ask for a Pizza Hut. Okay. The service you are calling is not available from this location. Oh. If this is an emergency.
第一本电话簿不会是一头白鲸。它会像一个小不点，像一条小鲱鱼。是的。同样，在大卫·华尔士的这通电话期间，德怀特问汤姆·彼得曼是否仍然负责白页账户。我们发现并没有。它现在由一位女性管理，但大卫不知道她的名字。菲利斯立刻振作起来。
Oh. Well, we'll never get Pizza Hut now. Nope. I'm just going to go without pizza today, I guess. Now you have me hungry for pizza. Sorry. Well, there you go. A little bit of the origin of the first phone book.
她就像，不，不，不。德怀特处理不了这笔生意。他对女人太糟糕了。是的，他一直叫吉娜·罗杰斯为吉娜。是的。她说她不得不纠正他五次。德怀特说，吉娜这么说的？这个场景实际上更长，在拍摄剧本中，德怀特随后转身对安吉拉说，我有没有让你感到不舒服过？它是这样写的。
The first phone book would not have been a whale. It would have been like a little, like a minnow. Yes. Also, during this phone call with David Wallace, Dwight asks if Tom Peterman is still in charge of the White Pages account. We find out no. It is now run by a woman, but David doesn't know her name. Phyllis immediately perks up.
德怀特，假的。安吉拉，当我在仓库里和你做爱时，我让你感到不舒服了吗？安吉拉迅速面对镜头。我在婚前是处女，而且我从未踏入过仓库。所以他们让我们拍了很多条，在其中一条里我们即兴发挥了，它被放进了删减片段中。我想让你听听。德怀特，你让女性感到不舒服。那，哦，拜托，这太不真实了。安吉拉，当我们在仓库开会时，我有没有让你感到不舒服？我们在仓库开过会吗？我有没有让你感到不舒服？那些会议非常简短。
She's like, no, no, no. Dwight cannot handle this sale. He is horrible with women. Yes, he kept calling Gina Rogers, Gina. Yes. She said she had to correct him five times. Dwight says, Gina said that? The scene was actually longer, and in the shooting draft, Dwight then turns to Angela
甚至可以说是乏味。我记得它们是……好吧，它们不是。哦，安吉拉，太搞笑了。我知道。这真是一个极好的即兴发挥。当我说是非常简短的时候，真的太有趣了。雷恩的表情是德怀特当时就像，等等。好吧，菲利斯是不会放过这件事的，伙计们。
and asks her, did I ever make you feel uncomfortable? This is how it read. Dwight, false, Angela, did I make you uncomfortable when I'd have sex with you in the warehouse? Angela quickly for camera. I was a virgin before marriage and I have never set foot in a warehouse. So they let us do a bunch of takes and in one we improvised and it made it into deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. Dwight you make women feel uncomfortable. That uh come on that is so not true. Angela when we would have meetings in the warehouse did I make you feel uncomfortable? would have meetings in the warehouse? Did I make you feel uncomfortable? Those meetings were very brief.
她说，听着，这么大一个账户可以翻倍。他们的总收入，你知道的，他们的薪水，他们的奖金，披萨星期五可能会回归。不过他们没办法打电话给必胜客了。没有411就不行。不，他们不能。潘说，吉姆，你能去吗？但他不能。他要参加他的新业务的第一次董事会电话会议。是的。是的。所以，他很忙。
Boring even. I remember them being... Well, they weren't. Oh, Angela, that is so funny. I know. That is such a good improv. It was so fun when I was like, it was very brief. I was like, rain's face was Dwight was like, wait. Well, Phyllis is not gonna let this go, you guys.
德怀特将负责推进这件事。哦，不。系好安全带。与此同时，我们还有另一条让我大笑的故事线。我们谈到了它，“胡子月”。皮特要走进休息室。我甚至不知道你会给这个起什么标题，休息室里的胡子。我想是的。休息室里的胡子。休息室里的胡子。他留着一小撮胡子，达瑞尔、克拉克和凯文也是。
She's like, listen, an account this size could double. They're gross, you know, they're salaries, they're bonuses, Pizza Friday could come back. They're not gonna be able to call Pizza Hut though. Not with 411. No, they're not. Pam says, Jim, can you go instead? But he can't. He has his first board meeting conference call for his new business. Yeah. Yeah. So, he's busy.
他们都刮得很不干净。皮特和克拉克有一个联合访谈镜头，他们说托比让他们参加“胡子月”。他们整个月都要留着胡子。所以，你知道，希望你喜欢一直处于被挑逗的状态。托比进来了，他留着一个非常，这是一个，这是一个松鼠尾巴。他非常骄傲。他显然能留胡子，一撮非常浓密的胡子。
Dwight's going to run point on this. Oh no. Buckle in. Meanwhile, we have this whole other storyline that really cracked me up. We talked about it, Movember. Pete is going to enter the break room. I don't even know what you would title this, Stashy in the Break Room. I guess so. Moostash in the Break Room. Moostash in the Break Room. He's got a little mustache and so do Daryl, Clark and Kevin.
当他，当保罗顶着那个走上片场时，我记得我笑疯了，因为它太稀疏、太奇怪了，垂在他的下巴上。我想让你知道，女士，当托比说他有非常肥沃的毛囊时，是的。我谷歌了这个。我想知道这是否是一回事。哦，肥沃的毛囊。是的。你想知道当你只输入“肥沃的毛囊”时弹出的第一件事是什么吗？
They're all very unshaven. Pete and Clark have a joint talking head where they say Toby got them to participate in Movember. And they're going to have mustaches the whole month. So, you know, hope you like being turned on all the time. Toby enters and he has a very, it's a, it's a squirrel. It's a squirrel tail. He's very proud. He can clearly grow a mustache, a very hearty mustache.
我想吗？我想吗？那是托比的一张照片！不！是的，那是弹出的第一件事。我觉得我没必要再往下看了。好吧。因为那太神奇了。
When he, when Paul walked on set with that, I remember losing it because it was so wispy and weird and it hung down on his chin. I want you to know, lady, when Toby says that he has very fertile hair glands, yes. I Googled that. I wondered if it was a thing. Oh, fertile hair glands. Yeah. Do you want to know the very first thing that comes up when you just type in fertile hair glands?
保罗·利伯斯坦，为了让你知道，在谷歌上，如果你输入“肥沃的毛囊”，就会弹出一张你的照片。那真是太不可思议了。好吧，托比很高兴这些家伙参加了“胡子月”。嗯，因为他现在有一个兄弟会了。是的。
Do I? Do I? It's a photo of Toby. No! Yep, it's the very first thing that comes up. I didn't feel like I had to go any further than that. Okay. Because that was amazing.
他们因为胡子而结缘。他们都在附楼里闲逛。他们去吃午饭，一起做事。他们在一起闲逛。这个场景更长，克里德要分享他留胡子的一次经历。我觉得我们应该听听。我以前留过一次胡子。
Paul Lieberstein, just so you know, on Google, if you type in fertile hair glands, a photo of you comes up. That is pretty incredible. Well, Toby is so delighted that these guys have participated in Movember. Well, because he's got a buddy group now. Yes.
一个女性朋友称它为“逗笑器”。她们把它直接插在胳肢窝里。好吧，我要说那是一个很好的剪辑。他们删掉了克里德说他的女性朋友叫他“逗笑器”的部分。是的。哦，这把我笑死了。好吧，我告诉你接下来这个场景有什么把我笑死了。
They're bonded over their mustaches. And they're all back in the annex hanging out. They go to lunch, they do stuff together. They're hanging out. The scene was longer, and Creed is going to share about a time he grew a mustache. I think we should hear it. I had a mustache once.
这是我最喜欢的场景之一。奥斯卡在做大扫除。他在清理他的办公桌抽屉。我想让你知道关于那个办公桌抽屉的每一个细节都是写进剧本里的。我知道，我查过了，我想，这到底是个什么梗？全部，整个过程，所有的细节都是写进剧本里的。他在清理这个抽屉，安吉拉说，
A lady friend's called it the tickler. They stick it right in their armpits. Well, I'm going to say that was a good edit. That they took out Creed saying his lady friends called him the tickler. Yes. Oh, it cracked me up. Well, I'll tell you what cracked me up this next scene.
我觉得参议员在搞婚外情，然后抽屉在他的手里脱臼了。太棒了。你知道当那发生时，就像你根本装不回去一样。不，不。凯瑞·肯珀说，这是她最喜欢的场景。她说她最初写的时候稍微有点不同。
This is one of my favorites. Oscar is doing some fall cleaning. He's cleaning out his desk drawer. I want you to know every single bit about that desk drawer was scripted. I know, I looked it up, I was like, what was this bit? All of it, the whole thing, all the details were scripted. He's cleaning out this drawer and Angela says,
这是我最喜欢的桥段之一。奥斯卡在做秋季大扫除。他在清理他的办公桌抽屉。我想让你们知道，关于那个抽屉的所有细节都是写好的剧本。我查过了，我当时想，这到底是什么梗？全部，整个过程，所有的细节都是设计好的。他正在清理这个抽屉，安吉拉说，
I think the senator is having an affair and the drawer comes unhinged in his hands. It is so good. And you know when that happens, it's like you can't get it back in there. No, no. Carrie Kemper said, this is her favorite scene. She said she originally scripted it a little differently.
我认为参议员有婚外情，然后抽屉在他手里卡壳脱落了。太精彩了。你知道那种情况发生时，就像你根本没法把它塞回去一样。是的，没错。凯里·肯珀说，这是她最喜欢的场景。她说她最初写的剧本稍微有点不同。
She said it was originally scripted in the kitchen and Oscar was gonna be toasting some bread. And you were gonna come in and say, I think the senator is cheating on me. And he was gonna accidentally knock the toast lever up and the toast was gonna go flying in the air and he was gonna like, swat at the toast. She said it was a little much. It got changed to the desk drawer gag, but she said she just loved seeing Oscar do physical
comedy and she really, she still kind of wishes that she would have gotten her toast gag because she thinks Oscar would have killed it. And she wanted to see your reaction of him like, swatting toast. It was just so funny. I can't even imagine him swatting toast. I wouldn't have been able to get through it. Also, Oscar feigning surprise or any emotion like that is just, he's brilliant. He's such a good actor. This cuts to a talking head with Oscar. He shares that he has had nightmares about this exact scenario.
And he wakes up in a sweat and makes Angela's husband spoon him back to bed. Well, there was actually one more scripted line after that line. It's in the shooting draft and I thought I'd read it to you. All right. After he says, I would make Angela's husband spoon me back to bed, he would then look ashamed and then look at camera and say, I'm one cold mother f***er. There was also a candy bag alt. It was a must shoot, so we did shoot it. Oscar would have said, I have nightmares in which Angela walks in on the senator and me.
I also have nightmares in which Angela and I have lunch. It's weird. Angela's in all my nightmares. I kind of love that. I did too. I love that the idea of the two of them having lunch is a nightmare. Well, Angela confides in Oscar that the senator
has a secret little smile on his face when he comes home in the morning. And Oscar makes a noise like, awww. And also, she says, the senator is always at this yoga studio. Yeah. He never misses noon hot yoga with Blake. And Oscar's like, you have nothing to worry about. Blake is also a guy's name.
So he could be spinning the day wait with the guy, wait a second. Yes. And then Oscar's like, who is this Blake? And Angel's like, yeah. And Oscar's like, I never heard anything about the Senator doing yoga, you know, from you. And I'm like, right?
What's with all the yoga? Exactly. And then Oscar's like, OK, calm down. But we have to check this out. And Angel's like, what? Yeah. He's like, okay, calm down. But we have to check this out. And Angela's like, what? Yeah, he's like, I'll go with you. I loved every second of this scene. It's delicious.
It's so good. I always thought a really fun spinoff would be Angela and Oscar being roommates. You know, when Angela moves in with him, we're not there yet. But I remember telling Greg, if I could see anything more of this show, it'd be Angela and Oscar living together. It's like the odd couple.
Yes, it's a really good idea. I know. All right, now we're going to go into the conference room and a bunch of the women in the office are trying to teach Dwight how to pitch to a female client. Yeah. It's not going great. No. No, they try to do some role-playing, but Dwight is just creepy.
Yeah. Dwight's like, no, I'm gonna tell her what her needs are and fill them all within 12 minutes. And everyone's like, okay, pump the brakes, buddy. We had a fan question from Zoe M in Arkansas who said, I was wondering if Nellie's lines about Dwight murdering women were improvised. It appears that Rainn Wilson almost breaks
after Catherine Tate finishes delivering her lines. Well, Zoey, they were scripted. Yes, they were. And afterward, Pam had a talking head. Here's what I said. I just want to make it clear that Dwight would never willingly harm a woman. Although, if she steps into one of his booby traps,
that's on her. Well, yeah. That goes for anyone. Yes, man or woman. That's true. Or animal. That's on you. That's right. I have a coffee mug callback. Ooh, I bet I know which one it is because Tess from London, England spotted it as well. Tess, did you see Meredith's coffee mug? It's the one where Kelly gives everyone a mug that came to her America's Got Talent party. Yes. Good catch guys. I still have mine. I didn't get one.
Pam didn't get one. I like that we're sing-songy. We're doing that thing like I didn't get one. Yeah, that's right. As if I'm not still bitter about it. I'm not angry. Because everyone got one by me. If I sing it, if I sing it, I'm not pissed. Well, Jim is gonna start his big conference call.
And guess what? He learns he's the only one calling in. Everyone else is in person, in the meeting. Yeah, and Kevin keeps distracting him. I love that they had him start with that rapper because someone opening up a noisy rapper of like any kind of food item would make me crazy. Crazy. Well, Jim is trying to, I guess he starts whispering
and they make fun of him for that. Then he tries to fix his voice and then they make fun of him for that. For that, Batman. Fan question from Samantha L in Tampa, Florida. Samantha says, is it just me or are Jim's colleagues at his new company kind of being jerks? I think they're a-holes.
Yeah, she says him whispering or talking in a deeper voice really isn't that big of a deal. Isn't one of them supposed to be his friend from college? This has always bothered me. Am I the only one? You are not the only one. I kind of felt like they were making fun of him or being too cool for school and exclusive. I didn't care for it.
I didn't like it. I didn't like it that they had absolutely like no compassion or patience. I agree, Samantha. I agree, Samantha. Well, we're going to get even more mail about this storyline later. It really triggered some people. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, the ladies are still trying to help Dwight in the conference room. Yes, we're going to learn Pam's selling to women rules.
Yes, and we're also going to watch Dwight creepily nod like he's listening. It's terrifying. We'll be right back. All right, we are back and here are Pam's selling to women rules. Okay, let's hear it. Listen, respect physical space. No eye rolling. Don't insult body. Don't compliment body. Don't compliment body. Don't mention body at all.
And then she's like Dwight, are you even listening because he just looks like a statue? A statue, yeah. And he's like, yes. And then she's like, look, see what I'm doing. I'm looking at you and I am nodding and I shows you that I am listening. And Dwight starts to do that and it's just so creepy.
So, so creepy. The ladies are not convinced that Dwight can do this. Meredith says we're screwed and then Phyllis tries some role-playing and says Dwight ignore every instinct you have. They're all garbage, okay? You're the woman. I'm the salesman. Watch what I do and try to learn. So Phyllis says, Miss Thomas, good to see you.' Dwight says, "'Hello.'" Phyllis goes, "'Oh, are those your kids? They're so cute. They could be models.'"
Dwight says, "'Thank you. I'm so proud of them. I carried each one of them for nine months inside my torso and then pushed them out of my vagina.'" Phyllis had to turn her head. Did you see it?
She's breaking. She's full-on breaking and had to physically turn away from the table. I did notice it. And you know who else noticed it? Destiny B from Folsom, California noticed it. It's at 10 minutes and 20 seconds. Yes, Destiny. She's totally breaking. And then right after that line, Meredith says, boo, weird.
Well, Pam decides she needs to go with Dwight. Yeah. So they're in the car together and she says, Dwight, you know, there's a lot of benefits to getting along with women. Yeah, Dwight's like, Pam, I don't have a problem with women. I have a problem with business women because they wear these suits and they have shoulder pads. He's very, very put off by shoulder pads. Yeah, he says, don't lie about your shoulders. Yeah
We had a fan question from Samantha L in Tampa, Florida who says Dwight kind of has a point here Why on earth were shoulder pads ever a trend? I thought about googling it But I had a suspicion that the office ladies who Google might already be on the case. You're not wrong Can we get a breakdown on the history of women's shoulder pads, please? Samantha, I want you to know whenever there's a line like this in an episode, like the phone book, the shoulder pads, Jenna and I get very excited. We're like, are you taking shoulder pads? I want phone book. It's true. I took shoulder pads. Yeah. And here is your brief history of the shoulder pad.
You might be interested in hearing that shoulder pads did not originate in women's clothing. The very first shoulder pad was invented in 1877 by a Princeton football player. I was going to say, isn't it like a sports thing? Yes, it was first used in American football. The first shoulder pads in fashion became popular in the 1930s when fashion designers Elson, Chapparelli, and Marcel Rokas started including them in their designs for women. Joan Crawford famously wore shoulder pads and they became quite a trend in the 1940s. But we all know the shoulder pad from the 1980s. They were the defining fashion statement of the 80s.
It became known as power dressing. It gave you the perception of status. It gave the appearance of authority and confidence. This is also why a lot of military uniform jackets, both men and women's, almost always have padded shoulders. Shoulder pads for women also make the shoulders and hips appear wider, thus making your waist look smaller. It gives you the illusion of an hourglass figure. They've had minor comebacks since the 80s, but really nothing as impactful.
I had a question when I was reviewing this. Why do I need an hourglass figure? Why is that like the thing? Like why do I need an hourglass figure? Why is that like the thing? Like why do I need a tiny waist? And by the way, I just full disclosure, this might be a question I'm asking because I don't have a waist. I have a cylinder for a body.
I have like a just like a, what it would like. I don't go in at the waist. Maybe I did when I was younger. Yes, everyone does when they're younger. But do you remember, I mean, there's a point in your life where you go to your family reunion and you're in your 20s and you're looking out at your aunts and they're all talking by the food table
and they all look like marshmallows with like toothpick legs. Yeah. That's the phase of life we're at. We're marshmallows with toothpicks. We've lost our waste. It happens. It does happen. And you know what? The fashion, though, is still designed for the waste.
Not for the marshmallow. I know. I know. And we need more fashion for the cylinder body. Yes. You know? Not for the hourglass. No.
For the straight, for the rectangle. I don't know what you call it. The marshmallow. Yes, I call it a marshmallow. But I go from my shoulder to my hips. It's just a straight line for the rectangle. I don't know what you would call it. Yes, I call it a marshmallow. But I go from my shoulder to my hips, it's just a straight line. Yes, right. So it wouldn't matter if you put shoulder pads on me.
No, it wouldn't. It's not, there's still no waist happening. You'd have to put giant shoulder pads on me. They never worked on me because shoulder pads are like one size fits all. But guess what? Not all shoulders are the same size. So you put a shoulder pad on me that you would put on someone taller.
And I lost my neck. It was like a little head sitting on these two little shelves. I don't know. I look like a turtle. I just remember that movie Working Girl. There were so many shoulder pads. So many shoulder pads. And I do remember Joan Crawford when she walks into that boardroom of the Pepsi Company and she goes, don't f*** with me fellas! Now Joan Crawford could do a shoulder
pad. She could. She gets the pass. She's the one. Yes. There it is. There it is. I hope you liked it. I liked it. I have one background. Catch here in this scene at 11 minutes and 16 seconds. Did anyone else watching this wonder what the heck Pam and Dwight are driving past? It looks like a bunch of orange vehicles, maybe like road crew vehicles, you know, or like some kind of transportation, orange vehicles. I didn't know this. And then lots of stuff that looks like bagged up trash. Anyone else go to 11 minutes, 16 seconds and be like, what the heck is that?
What was it? I don't know. Oh, I took a screen grab. We're questioning it. We're not answering it. Does anyone else know? Please write me. Well, we got another fan question about this scene
from Gabriel M. in Brazil, who said after four years, you guys might be able to finally end my seven year long quest. There is a deleted scene where Pam and Dwight are in the car and Dwight is hyping himself up to some loud metal. Yes, he's hyping himself up to go win this big sale. Yes, they're actually in the parking lot
outside of the building where they're gonna do the sale. He's doing that thing that he does, right? So Gabriel goes on to say that after seeing Pam's discomfort to this metal music, Dwight changes to a softer song. Gabriel says, do you guys know either the song or the singer of the softer song? I love that little snippet of it, but I've never been able to find it. Well, I remember shooting this, but I couldn't remember the songs.
And I didn't recognize it when I rewatched it. That's because Steve Burgess told me that it was scripted to switch from a Metallica track to a Carpenter's track. Okay. Metallica said yes. Great. The Carpenter said no. So then what'd we switch to?
We ended up recording it with no music. And this is why I couldn't remember. We added the music in post and we just used what Steve called library tracks. It's just generic tracks of styles of music. It's much less expensive. But Steve said, unfortunately, didn't have any information about it,
but it's kind of like the stock photo of the music world. So it was, they were not like songs that we could point to. They were just this stock music. That's why I couldn't figure it out. Yes, and also Gabriel, why you couldn't figure it out? Right. Well, Angela and Oscar are now at the yoga studio. They're actually in a food court
where they can look through like a glass window into the yoga studio. Yeah, you guys are drinking, what are you drinking? Shakes? Are you drinking smoothies? They were like smoothies. Okay.
The senator walks in with a very petite blonde. This really, really sends Angela off. Oh, she's a double zero for sure. Yeah. For sure. And then she starts adjusting his hips for downward dog. Angel's like, I have heard of this. Yeah.
Dog style. But then a guy walks up with a ponytail and gives the yoga instructor a big hug, and Angela is so relieved. She's like, oh, guy with a ponytail. I'd like to see that run for office. Yes, but then Oscar sees the senator hugging a man who then starts giving him some adjustments as he's doing his yoga pose. Yeah. He says, Angela's ready to leave, but Oscar says no. Shut up or staying.
The plot thickens. Jim is still trying to take this phone call and make this meeting happen. He now goes outside, but there's construction going on. And then he kind of leans on Meredith's van and sets an alarm off. And this is my favorite line of the whole episode. Hank comes out and is like, are those skateboarders back? And then Meredith is like, who is messing with my van? And then Hank yells, and this is my favorite line. This ends now!
Like he is done. He is ready to take on this whole pack of skateboarders. And poor Jim is like, where can I talk to these people? Oh, where can you talk to these people, Jim? We've got a fan mail flurry to answer that question. What is it? It really teed some people off. Fan question from Deanna H in Plant City, Florida, who said, why wouldn't Jim just go into Andy's office to make the call? Andy isn't there. go into Andy's office to make the call. Andy isn't there. Sarah C. from New Jersey said, I have been waiting so long to comment on Jim's phone call.
I was so frustrated with Jim in this episode because there was no need for this, Jim. Here is a list of 10 places where Jim could have taken that call. I can't wait to hear this because one place came to mind immediately for me. I bet you can guess it. I don't know. It's where all the secret stuff happens. The secret stairwell.
The stairwell. Why didn't he go to the stairwell? Yes, that was number four on her list. Let's hear the rest. All right. Number one, Andy's office. Number two, Darryl's office. Surely Darryl would have given him his office for this.
I mean, how long is this phone call going to be? Not long. Three, inside gonna be, not long. Three, inside Pam and Jim's car. Yeah, I thought of that too. The stairwell? Mm-hmm. Number five, close off the break room like how Toby did when he was having a counseling session with Michael.
Six, the former Michael Scott paper company room. There it is. Seven, the room that they used for spying on Danny Cordray. Number eight, the Dwight Shrewt Gym for Muscles. Number nine, Ryan's closet. Oh yeah. Number 10, the closet near accounting where Jim and Pam sneak off in the episode PDA.
This is a really good list. Really good list. I understand the whole list. The only two that I think would be difficult are Andy's office and Daryl's office. I'll tell you why. Why? Because people can look in and be nosy and be like, Hey, what are you doing in here? Like Kevin would be like, What's up?
What were you doing in here? Are we hanging out? Yeah. All the rest, I think, make sense. I've got another one. Home. Home. Go home. Who's in the office that's going to give you grief about it?
Dwight has left and Andy's not there. Yeah. Toby is completely distracted by his Movember gang. Just sneak out and go home and take the call. Go home. They don't live that far. No. Dwight and Pam are now walking into the office where they're going to meet this new prospective client.
And Pam asks the receptionist Molly for the woman's name, but Molly won't tell her the name. And Pam starts to look around the room and Jen, I thought your performance was so great as you start to see multiple clues that this is Jan. Yes. You know, I asked Carrie about her role as Molly because she's so funny. I remember she did it at the table read, which often happened. Like writers would read some of the smaller roles because sometimes those roles would get cut after the table read, so they didn't want to cast them
until they were like... Locked in, yeah. Yes. So she said that after the table read, they asked her to play the part. And she said she had used to act in musicals in high schools and college, but had never done any on-camera work before. And she said, one of the things that she remembered the most from the shoot, it's a very funny story. She said she remembered walking on set
and that I looked at her and I said, oh my gosh, I think you're wearing one of your sister's outfit. One of Erin's outfit? Yes. Because you know, that would happen sometimes. We would have guest actors and I would look over and they would be wearing some of Pam's clothes. Yeah.
This happened. I'd be like, I think that's my jacket. Yeah. And so, yes, it turns out if you look at this outfit, it is one of Erin's outfits. She was wearing an Erin outfit, which I actually think is a really sweet nod to them being sisters. Yeah, I do too.
Well, Jan is not happy that it is Dwight and Pam. She was really hoping for a reunion, a revenge union with David Wallace. Dwight is gonna try to butter her up by complimenting Astrid saying she could be a bubble bath model. So creepy, Dwight. Melora does something in this scene that I had to go back, I had to rewind because I
thought it was so great. It's not in the script. It's just Melora being Jan and she's so brilliant. While she's frustrated in talking to them, Jan picks up a frame and wipes the dust off with her boob on herob. I noticed that. On her shirt. It's so funny. That is not in the script.
Melora is so good. We got a lot of fan mail. People wanted to know whose idea it was to bring Melora back. Well, it was Greg. In this final season, he wanted us to touch base with some of the office favorites. Remember, David Denman came back for Roy's wedding.
So this was the Jan episode. And I traded texts with Melora because after I watched this episode, I was just like, God, she's so good. She's so good. She said it was so great to get to come back and see everybody. She said she especially loved all of the Pam
and Jan awkward interactions. And I had to ask her about that skydiving photo. I was like, did you, what is that? Like, well, how did you do that? Because it was scripted that there was going to be the skydiving photo in the office. And it's really big. It takes up the whole wall. She said that she had to come in one day and they put her in a skydiving suit, and they had her lay on a table that was green. And then they set up a fan and they blew it in her face. And then in post, they removed the table and they put in the sky background.
And that's how they got that picture. By the way, Angela, I don't know if you know this. There is a huge monk crossover with Melora. Yes, I have been told this. She plays Trudy Monk. Yes. She is his ex-wife who was killed in a car bomb. And she comes back like as an apparition sometimes.
Yes, and her murder is the only one that Adrian Monk has not been able to solve. It was like this whole runner of the series. I'll have you know, she is back for the Monk movie Monk's Last Case. Oh, I am not because my character went to jail. Sorry for the spoiler. Yeah.
Well, I loved all the little accents on Jan's desk. I'm sure a lot of you noticed these as well. She has her serenity candle. She has a fancy pin set. She has clacky balls. Clacky balls. Yes. Oh, you know what? has clacky balls. Clacky balls. Yes. Oh, you know what?
My clacky balls are tangled. Oh, you have to bring them in for Cassie. We need Cassie to untangle my clacky balls. Jan not only has clacky balls, but she has basket of balls. And then she has one of those little minis in like Sand Garden. A little garden. And I just love the physical comedy callback
that when Jan got stressed, she lit one of her own candles and started to- She wafts it. Wafts it. Mm-hmm. I love that too. Well, it becomes very clear to Pam very quickly that Jan has no intention of giving them her business.
So she's like, we need to go. But Dwight is like, no, stay here. I have an idea. And he leaves. And Pam has to sort of just fill the time until Dwight gets back. The scene was much longer of Pam trying to bond with Jan. I really want you to hear it, it's in deleted scenes. Astrid will be fine.
My sperm donor was a Caltech physicist. Your sperm donor sells paper. By my sperm donor, do you mean my husband too? I'm just saying your sperm was free. You get what you pay for. By my sperm donor, do you mean my husband? I'm just saying your sperm was free. You get what you pay for. Well, Jim and I love each other, so that's got to be worth something.
So now you're saying that I'm unlovable. That's what you're basically saying. I'm very sorry. I am. I mean, is that it, Pam? No. That's I'm sorry. No, I get it.
I hear it. Do you have another one of these? The slide shows? Let's see it. Molly! Oh my goodness. Jan is so unpredictable. Pam is just trying to like have a conversation. Are you saying I'm unlovable?
Like, wait, how do we get there? But she's also like trying to defend herself because Jan is insulting her. I know. Oh my goodness. I also feel like we have to talk about the slideshow and the song. And this is the last time we're gonna hear Jan sing. Yes.
And we need to hear it. Okay. Mommy, you're a princess. Mommy, you're a superstar. Mommy, you're a superstar. Mama, you're the greatest. How could I ever fail your shoes? Wow. Wow is right.
Wow. It's the only response to that. Wow. Wow. Oh, Malora, amazing, amazing job. Well, there's a little flirty at reception happening. There is. Pete is trying to talk to Erin, but she's very grossed out by his mustache. Here's a list of all the insults Erin says to Pete. I mean, she says them nicely. She says there's an eyebrow in the middle of your face. She
says your handsome eyebrow makes it look like your mouth is like an eye socket. She also says he looks like a cyclops but whose eye fell out. And Pete immediately goes and shaves off the mustache. Exactly. November is over now for Pete. Back at the yoga studio, Oscar and Angela continue to spy on the senator and Oscar suggests that maybe the affair that Angela should be worried about is with this man. Yeah, I was like Oscar what Angela, I'm dehydrated. Maybe you heard me wrong, we should just go.
And then Angela's like, oh, here he comes, what's he doing? And Oscar says he's making a phone call. And then Oscar's phone rings. This is how the stage direction was written for this moment in the shooting draft. Okay. Suddenly Oscar's phone rings. Angela looks at the phone.
Oscar fumbles with it, trying to turn it off. Angela looks from Oscar to the senator and back. Oscar looks at her guiltily. She reads it in his face and knows. Very interesting, that all played out. I mean, I saw all of that play out in your scene. Well, you know, we filmed this scene multiple times. They kept moving the camera around
because they really wanted to make sure that they could capture Oscar and I looking at each other, but that we were also hidden from the senator, but that the camera could see the senator. So they kept moving the camera around and I actually have all of the unedited takes from this moment. Really?
Yeah. They were given to me way back when I found him in my digital clutter and I have all of them. The moment the phone rings and I look at him. In some takes, they had me grab my coat and walk off in a huff. And then other takes, they just had me hold the stare at him. And that's what they used.
Wow. Well, it's really funny when I was watching this episode and I saw these scenes, I was like, why do I feel like I was there? This was a location. I wouldn't have been there. But Angela, I was. I was. Steve Burgess reminded me that we shot this yoga studio at the 360 Health Club in Recita, California. In the morning, we shot in the parking lot. We shot that scene of me and Dwight out in the car. And we did all of our driving scenes around this area. And I came in and I said, hi to you guys, because they were setting up your interior work.
So I was there. Oh my gosh. I know, I totally remember it. Our base camp was in the parking lot. And so I was there that day. I remember. And I love those scenes. Thank you, I absolutely love them
and I loved rewatching them. And I wanna call Oscar and be like, Oscar, let's do a show. You should. Well Dwight is now gonna come back to Jan's office and guess who he has in tow? Clark. Clark.
Clark, like as a token? Like Dwight is offering up Clark to Jan? What the heck? Well, he says, Molly is a crap assistant. You can have Clark. Yeah. How about that? Pam's like, Clark, you don't have to do this. And he goes, no, I want to get ahead. I want to get ahead in the paper sale industry.
Do you know why the storyline was in place? Where was Clark in real life going? Had he booked a movie? Exactly. Yes, he had. Clark needed time off to go film kick-ass, too So we put Ed on a boat because he was off filming hangover three We gave Clark to Jan because he had to film kick-ass, too Also after we shot this episode we took a three-week hiatus to give these gentlemen a little bit more time to do their movies Oh Hmm. Oh, hmm.
Well, that is- Did you hear that? It's exactly one year ago at the same time that I was asking for maternity leave. Correct. And I was told we can't do that. No. We can't take three week break
so that you can heal from birthing a human. Yeah, we couldn't do that. We'd done it all the other years for a movie project seasons one through seven. And then again here in season nine, but apparently in season eight, we just couldn't. You know what? You should have been in kick ass three. Maybe if I'd done Blades of Glory 2, I could have had three weeks off. I don't know what Kick-Ass is.
I don't know Kick-Ass 1. Oh, it's a really funny movie. I need to see it. Yeah. I mean, I love Clark. But yeah, I hear you on all of that. Yeah. I hear ya.
我不知道《海扁王1》。哦，那是一部非常搞笑的电影。我得去看看。是的。我的意思是，我喜欢克拉克。但是的，你说的那些我都赞同。是的。我懂你的意思。
Anywho, I'll leave it there. We'll leave it there and we're gonna save it for our spin-off podcast. Obviously, these ladies burn it to the ground. This episode ends with Pam and Dwight. They are leaving and they run into Molly. And Pam says, I think you should quit. And Dwight wishes her luck with her feelings.
总之，我就聊到这儿吧。我们就聊到这儿，留着以后在我们的衍生播客里说吧。显然，这些女士们把这里炸翻天了。这一集以帕姆和德怀特结束。他们要离开了，然后遇到了莫莉。帕姆说，我觉得你应该辞职。德怀特则祝她处理好自己的感情。
Pam is like, wow, Dwight, you should ask her for her number. And then he says, I already did. He reads off what's clearly a license plate. And Pam says, oh, is that her license number? Lady, I was very confused why you would call it a license number. Oh. So I went to the shooting draft and your actual line is, Dwight, that's a license plate.
帕姆好像在说，哇，德怀特，你应该要她的电话号码。然后他说，我已经要了。他读出的明显是一个车牌号。帕姆说，哦，那是她的车牌号吗？天哪，我很困惑你为什么会管它叫车牌号码。哦。所以我去查了拍摄初稿，你真正的台词其实是，德怀特，那是块车牌。
But I said license number and I stayed in. You just fumbled it and it stayed in. But it cracked me up and it's a very sweet moment though between Dwight and Pam because Dwight says you're my friend. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I always love those moments. There's a really great episode coming up that actually Lee, my husband Lee directed.
但我说的是车牌号码，而且还被剪进去了。你只是说错了，然后就被保留了下来。但这让我大笑，不过这确实是德怀特和帕姆之间非常温馨的时刻，因为德怀特说你是我的朋友。对。对。对。我总是很喜欢那些时刻。接下来有一集非常棒的剧集，实际上是由我的丈夫李执导的。
It's vandalism and Pam and Dwight are going to team up to figure out who vandalized something. I won't, I guess, spoil it, but. This is a duo I love. I love Pam and Dwight and I love Angela and Oscar. Me too. All right, you guys, that was The Whale. We want to thank you all for writing in and sending your questions and your comments. We love them so much. A big thank you to Steve Burgess, Carrie Kemper, and to Melora Hardin, who, by the way, I don't know if you know this,
那是《破坏公物》，帕姆和德怀特将组队查出是谁破坏了公物。我想我就不剧透了吧。这是我非常喜欢的一个二人组。我喜欢帕姆和德怀特，我也喜欢安吉拉和奥斯卡。我也是。好了，各位，这就是《鲸鱼》。我们要感谢大家写信并发送你们的问题和评论。我们太喜欢它们了。非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、凯瑞·肯珀，以及梅洛拉·哈丁，顺便说一句，我不知道你们知不知道，
but she started a line of wallpaper. Yes, it's beautiful. Beautiful. And she also stars in a one-woman film called Golden Vanity. The film has won several awards at various film festivals, including three Best Actress Awards for Melora. You can learn more about the movie and more about her wallpaper at malora.com. But don't you worry, because I'll put it in stories. You all with a Swipey. Yes, you will.
但她创立了一个壁纸系列。是的，非常漂亮。非常漂亮。她还主演了一部名为《金色虚荣》的独角戏电影。该片在各大电影节上赢得了多个奖项，其中包括为梅洛拉赢得的三项最佳女主角奖。你可以在 malora.com 上了解更多关于这部电影和她壁纸的信息。不过不用担心，因为我会把它发到快拍里。你们所有人都可以向上滑动查看。是的，你会的。
All right, bye, you will. Alright, bye you guys! See you next week! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins, our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer, our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
好了，拜拜，你会的。好了，大家拜拜！下周见！感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用兑换码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。